la nuque comme la majorité revendique ce
matin toutes les deux la victoire de
quoi créer une polémique c'est plus
possible que un ministre de l'Intérieur
puisse refuser une étiquette comme il
l'a refusé pour nous la nuit puis a
fallu que ce soit le tribunal qui
l'oblige le mettre puis manipule des
résultats en reclassant les gens en
cours de route la gauche rassemblée
autour de Jean-Luc Mélenchon aligné sur
Jean-Luc Mélenchon arrive à mobiliser
près de 25% ce qui n'est pas énorme
c'est les références qu'on avait déjà en
2017 c'est zéro dans des cas avec vous
oui mais si c'est pas énorme pour lui
c'est pas énorme non plus pour vous ah
mais je suis pas en train de nous dire
que c'est énorme pour nous ce serait
idiot de dire ça et ça n'est pas à ma
culture ni d'être idiot ni de mentir en
réalité c'est que ils font moins bien
lors de ces élections législatives
qu'ils n'ont fait avec leur score cumulé
au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle voilà donc tout ça pour
ça
et puis avec un certain nombre de
mensonges diffusés hier soir sur le
nombre de présence aux alentours etc etc
un certain nombre de cand qui en réalité
sont des candidats de la Nouvelle Union
populaire écologique et sociale ne sont
pas comptabilisées comme tel et donc
artificiellement le ministre de
l'Intérieur essaye de faire figurer les
candidats de la majorité en tête on est
chez Monsieur Bompard dans le classique
théorique du complot évidemment le monde
entier leur en veut il se trouve que il
parle de gens qui le soutiennent
maintenant alors qu'ils les soutenait
pas il y a deux jours et il voudrait les
comptabiliser parce qu'il les soutient
maintenant bon tout ça n'est pas très
sérieux ce qui m'a fait rigoler c'est
Monsieur Castaner qui est quand même à
droite au premier prix
cette année quoi c'est vraiment un aigle
après avoir inventé qu'on vous
l'empêcher des gens de couper du bois
voilà que maintenant il dit je vais
prendre mes ordres à Moscou nous avons
proposé l'Union aux autres parties de
droite il n'en ont pas voulu la gauche a
eu la voie libre et l'on voit ce soir le
résultat autre revers à Montargis dans
le Loiret après 5 ans à l'éducation
nationale l'ancien ministre Jean-Michel
Blanquer et lui aussi éliminé il annonce
un recours j'ai échoué à peu de voix en
dans une campagne qui a été émaillée
d'incident la première ministre
Elisabeth borne arrive en tête dans sa
circonscription du Calvados avec plus de
34% des voix mais trois membres du
gouvernement donc Clément Beaune et
Amélie de mon Chalain sont en ballotage
défavorables nous sommes la force
politique qui a le plus de candidats au
deuxième tour nous avons des candidats
de la majorité présidentielle dans les
trois quarts des circonscriptions nous
avons besoin notre pays a besoin d'une
majorité forte et claire et c'est ce
pourquoi nous allons nous battre toute
la semaine la majorité présidentielle
actuelle étant passe de devenir la
minorité présidentielle et que nous
sommes dans une situation où
effectivement la gauche peut l'emporter
sur notre position elle est conforme à
la ligne qui a toujours été celle de
notre famille politique aucune voie sur
la ne doit se porter sur les extrêmes
c'est très clair aucune voie pour le
Front National et ensuite quand on a un
candidat républicain et c'est le cas par
exemple pour Fabien Roussel nous le
soutenons quand vous avez un candidat
qui ne respecte pas nos valeurs
républicaines nous ne le soutenons pas
une vague de chaleur est attendue à
partir de mercredi en France avec des
températures entre 35 et 38 degrés sur
la moitié sud dans un contexte de
sécheresse qui fait déjà craindre pour
les récoltes pas une voix ne doit aller
sur l'extrême droite mais ne me donne
pas d'aller faire campagne pour des
candidats qui s'assoient notamment sur
celles et ceux qui au quotidien risque
leur vie pour nous défendre il est
possible que le seuil de canicule soit
atteint voire dépassé sur certains
départements il se pourrait alors que
Météo France déclenche des vigilances
oranges voire rouge pour faire face aux
risques sanitaires à partir du moment où
vous avez un un président sortant qui ne
veut à aucun moment débattre des sujets
ni ne dire en fait ce qu'il veut faire
pour les 5 ans qui viennent et qu'il
gagne par défaut et ben un jour ou
l'autre on en paye le prix et c'est ce
qui va arriver d'abord par l'abstention
massive et puis ensuite malheureusement
probablement dans la rue